[Music]
let's go to
the home of the great chuck liddell san
luis obispo california and talk to
jessica hey jessica what's up
hi john how are you so good how are you
i'm doing good
so what in the world is going on
well i have a question for you of how to
handle my husband um basically back in
the way you asked that was incredible
so sorry
back in 2007 my husband and i were in a
situation where we had four kids and we
had paid off our house so we were in a
really good situation
so i wanted to work part-time and so we
were both working part-time
and it was working and then i wanted to
get a bigger house so
i made a deal with him i said if we can
get a bigger house i'll go back to work
full time and then you can go and be a
stay-at-home dad again
so we did that and now it's 2022
the kids are older the youngest are in
10th and 12th grade
and i would like him to go back to work
and he refuses he says no you made a
deal
and you have to stick to it
you made a deal was this vegas what
he made a deal
where
the deal was
i wanted a bigger house
he was happy with the little house
i said
you know i personally i felt suffocated
i felt like a rat who was gonna you know
like go crazy one day in that tiny house
so i said okay if we get a bigger house
i'll go back to work full time and then
you can stay at home with the kids
and
now that the kids are older
they don't need him anymore at home he
needs to go in and
be
you know providing for the family too
oh man
he refuses he says no
you made a deal we're going to stick to
it the kids need me and i say no they
don't need you they're in 12th grade and
10th grade and they're good they don't
drink they don't smoke they don't do
drugs they don't have sex they don't do
they don't get in trouble with the
police they're there we've done our job
jessica they do all those things they
just don't tell you i'm totally kidding
i'm telling you no they don't i know
they don't
like it so um
there's something way beneath this
yes there's lots of things way beneath
this trust me
i i can feel it through the phone can i
just can i cut to it and you tell me if
i'm wrong
you absolutely
in no way shape form or fashion do you
have an ounce of respect for this man
that's yes that's the problem and that's
he doesn't he wants me to respect him
and to do what he says
and he gets a little
not he's not like mean but
you know he knows
that i don't give him the respect that i
should as a christian wife
and
the reason is because it's very hard to
respect a man who
doesn't want to take care of himself or
his family the way that i assume that a
man should want to do
so let's take the
christian wife baggage off of this for a
second let's just talk about human
dignity
okay okay this is a guy
i was gonna ask you tell me about his
physicality
yes that is another problem is um the
reason why i want him to go back to work
is basically because
basically for the whole or we've been
married almost 27 years and for the past
27 years i've always been the one to
provide the health benefits through my
my working places
and
it's really frustrating to me because
he's overweight and he refuses to lose
his weight he just thinks it's funny and
he has type 2 diabetes and he's
expensive
and it's i feel that it's unfair that
i'm
shelling out an extra 6 000 a year to
help pay for his medicine
and
he won't even you know provide for his
the cost of you know if he had a job in
california working 30 hours a week you
get benefits
so even if he worked yeah but this this
is this isn't about that so let me hear
me say
as clearly as i can
he needs to get his butt off the couch
and contribute
okay
i can't do it full stop full stop he's
got to get off his butt and contribute
contribution looks different in all
sorts of ways
but he's got to contribute
but
you're talking about a vicious shame and
blame cycle that you all two have
created and this is probably a 25-year
dance
where why in the world would he want to
participate
in home building relationship
connectivity with somebody who acts like
his mom
who's always on him about you need to do
this and you do this and this is what i
signed up for and you're not the kind of
man or whatever and
why in the world would you want to
create a world with a guy
who's
literally killing himself slowly
diseases of despair this is a long tail
suicide i'm not going to move i'm not
going to have any purpose i'm going to
sit around here and i'm going to eat i'm
not going to exercise my body's just
going to fall apart on me
why would you want to connect to that
you see like both of you
are plugs and you've got the
those plug covers that you put when
there's newborns in the house
this is not happening
and right now you get into this world of
uh
blame and finger-pointing because you
don't like who you've become he didn't
like who he's become but there's nobody
there to anchor into because it's just
this loop-de-loop-de-loopty loop
have you found somebody else
nope over 25 years
nope
so walk me through how lonely it's been
for a quarter of a century
well it's not that lonely don't forget
we have four kids no no that's not
that's not intimacy those are kids
true
well actually we do
we do have a lot of things in common
that we do like to do together and we do
have
you can distract yourself
and he's probably funny and he's
probably fun to be around and you all
both like watching nascar or whatever
the thing is
yeah but you don't like him
well i don't i don't know i mean he says
that sometimes he's like i don't think
you like me jessica
i just met you you don't like him
you don't like him
okay so now what he may not
say it say it and he may not be likable
and so whenever we run up against this
this dance
somebody
somebody has to say enough i'm stopping
this
i'm stopping
but here's the thing
you cannot stop the dance
through finger-pointing and grenade
throwing
you can only stop the dance by saying
what can i control in this dance
and the only thing you can control is
you
okay
and what do i do
you don't like you either
okay is that true am i wrong
maybe you like you you don't like who
you've become
yeah i guess i don't like i don't like
i don't know
i don't think i don't like me i think i
i
i feel like i got the short end of the
stick that's right you're this perpetual
victim you don't like where your life
has ended up and it's everybody else's
fault and
you got you got a husband who's not
doing anything so there is some
contribution there make no mistake okay
but what i want you to do is to stop
looking externally
for the solutions to why you feel the
way you feel inside
and instead say what can i control in
this situation
when's the last time
i exercised when's the last time i sat
down and said
the way you treat me and
you
a guy i love the way you treat yourself
breaks my heart
and
i can't do anything about it so i'm
through fighting you i'm through yelling
at you
i'm not gonna sit here and just watch
you die which is what you're doing
you're killing yourself in our living
room i can't be a part of that
i'm out what's kept you from doing that
um
actually
we just had this conversation not that
long ago
so i did
explain to him that
you know he wasn't contributing enough
and it's not fair to me and i i trust me
we fight about the exercise and the
losing weight a lot
and i do exercise so i mean i've yeah
i've i've exercised
to the you know i was doing the whole
over 10 000 steps a day for a long long
time so i'm i do exercise and hike and
all of that my personal self i got that
but listen you started the conversation
with him about this isn't fair to me
that's correct it's a victim language
right it's not it's not power owning
language
i want you i want you to to take
your power back
and to say take here i want you to take
ownership of yours
here's the problem that that i'm having
so
so
you know how you said that i was like
being the mother to him
he hates it when he's like you're trying
to be the boss you're trying to be in
charge of everything around here and
that's not your role and i say yes i
know and he's like i you know i'm in
charge blah blah blah blah what which is
listen you have a screwed up power
dynamic it's you versus him
and it's got to be all together
exactly and that's that's the thing so i
that's why so stop fighting you can't
win this 26 years try something new okay
twenty twenty six years i do
because i here's what i've tried in the
past i've tried
just shutting up and saying nothing i've
tried being a complete [ __ ]
i've tried um just doing my own thing
i've tried um
i've tried just pretending in my head
that he's on disability and there's
something wrong with him to just suck it
up and do it
i've tried pretending like he's hired
help and his job is to take care of the
kids so you can't expect anything else
like i've tried all of these things in
my head done the mental gymnastics but
the one thing you had all those things
mentioned you
and
mentioned him
talking about you okay
okay so tell me what i need to do
because i've i don't know what else to
do because i do
work all day
and then come home and do you know he
does a lot he does
um you know
make the dinners and he does you know do
stuff like that he takes the kids to
school and he does do the grocery
shopping and stuff like that he doesn't
do nothing completely but
i just
i mean
okay so the problem is that he's trying
to control the money too saying that i
shouldn't buy this i shouldn't do this
because
blah blah blah and i'm thinking well if
you had a job then we would have the
money to do that and we have money
that's what's frustrating
when i was
i don't know 22 23 college
i thought i was mr mma guy
and i thought honor and
power and strength was about flexing all
the time
i was always on the lookout for
who's disrespecting who and who can i
protect and
do you look at my wife i was that guy
what an idiot yeah what an idiot
and then after i spent a few years with
professional fighters their job their
paycheck is punching other people in the
face for money
i realized a few things number one
you never know
one of the worst beatings i ever took in
my life in training was from a 5-3
nurse named mateo and he worked me over
sideways i still remember it
and
here's what it did it humbled me in a
dramatic way
and
i started thinking huh
if i wait until
there's a
altercation which by the way never
happens
if i wait for an altercation to display
to my wife that i love her what a loser
i am
so then i started displaying love to my
wife all the time
and what that freed me from was having
to flex it i just i'm not gonna fight
anybody i'm going home this is stupid
i'm leaving you say whatever you want
about me and my family congratulations i
hope you have a great day i'm out of
here that's not honor that's not
integrity that's cowardice in being a
child
so here's what i'm telling you
when i walk through the world looking
for oh yeah oh yeah
that's not that's not right step up
all i could see all day long was that
nonsense
and then when i said all right dude i'm
not i'm i'm just not i'm out
i can't describe the piece i just don't
i don't fight have a good day right and
here's what i'm telling you that
at some point basically you're saying to
look for the good no no no no no not the
bad you have to have an or what moment
and you haven't had it yet
okay what does that mean are you gonna
leave
no ever
no
there we are
so just suck it up no
suck it up is different than make peace
okay
okay
suck it up is different than make peace
suck it up is i'm gonna grip my teeth
i'm gonna grind my way through this
and peace is
i really love you
and i hate the fact that you're killing
yourself in our house
we have these goals together let's dream
about what this could look like
not about what's fair to me and fair to
you and who gets to control this and
control that
let's dream about what this could look
like
and well what if we have different goals
like he's completely satisfied with the
status quo of
of
his
his health he's completely satisfied
with the status quo how he how he keeps
house he doesn't think that it it needs
repairs and things like that
and
you know i would like to have people
over to the house but because he's so
messy i can't
why are you why are you staying in this
marriage
well
it's not a reason to get a divorce just
because somebody's messy
you know what i mean that's not a thing
that you would get a divorce over i know
but it's a thing that you are killing
yourself over
the age the rage and the anger and the
frustration and the constant
is killing you
yeah but that's not i mean there are
lots of people who have messy spouses
who don't get divorced over that that's
not a that's not a reason to get a
divorce so what is his like what is his
behavior trying to tell you
he's happy he doesn't he doesn't
he sees nothing wrong with
the way it is
he he doesn't he doesn't think that
his dad was very messy so he's very
messy so he doesn't when he looks at the
mess he doesn't see it the way i look at
it
and then he thinks that i'm trying to
keep up with the joneses and trying to
argue impress somebody
yeah i just want to be normal
i'm not trying to keep up with the
choices well and i just your picture of
normal again i'm not in your house i
can't see it and this may be a totally
different conversation
but you all have a different definition
of what's normal and here's the thing
you're
have you heard me talk about pictures
and words
no
so
one of the chief challenges with all
marriages is that we think in pictures
but we speak in words
and you look at him
and you have a picture
of a lazy
respect-free slob who is wasting his
life and is keeping you from having
community and friends because of how he
lives
that's a picture in your picture
and your words you used to communicate
that are you're not healthy
you're not even you're a bum what are
you doing
and he's got a picture of what happy
looks like and that is i don't even have
to get a job my life's awesome we made
it i made a deal 30 years ago this is
incredible
and uh
it's cool my wife and i have some good
laughs and some good fun
i saw how my dad did it and that's
pretty much what's happening here i got
great kids
we're doing something right i'm good
and what you haven't done for him y'all
you're using the same words and you're
just going right past each other
so you got to paint a picture here is
not like when he says when you say i
just want to be normal
he's saying i've got a picture of normal
and this is it and you're saying right
i've got a picture of normal and it
looks like her house or that guy's house
or it feels like people come over and
i'm not embarrassed
correct and so what you guys have to do
you got to do this
is you'll have to go
spend some time together painting a
picture here's what this means for me
and here's what this means for him and
what i'm telling you is this if he looks
at your picture and says i will never do
that
i don't love it
it's exhausting i'm scared i'm something
i will never do that
then you jessica have a decision to make
one of three choices
i'm gonna nag him until he dies
i'm just gonna continue to lean in lean
in lean in poke poke poke say it be
frustrated be angry
you can leave him which i don't think is
the right move
or
you can say
i love you enough to not like let you
just die like this
but i also know i can't make you
work
i can't make you be a participant in
this home
and it breaks my heart and i'm sorry
my picture for us is
that we have people over and the house
looks like this and here's an actual
picture
my picture is is that my husband doesn't
have type 2 diabetes because he doesn't
take care of his body he's not a good
steward of it
my picture is not that you treat me
fairly that you get your job and i get
my job and i've been giving you health
insurance
my
picture is is that we get back to
laughing really hard and that you like
me again and i like you again
and so the only thing i can control here
is that i'm just gonna start liking you
again for all of your quirks and
weirdness and whatever i am gonna hire
somebody to clean the house because i
want people over and you refuse to do
that so i'm gonna hire somebody to clean
the house
and that's gonna cut into some of your
video game time or your whatever time
and i am going to
fill in the blank i'm going to start
backfilling some of these things
and you can choose to look at him as a
leech
as somebody who is sucking your soul out
of your life and he might be
but if you're not going to leave
then you can either choose to make peace
with what is
or
continue to go to war inside your body
every single day and what i'm telling
you is not just give up and i'm just
going to cook ties but no i'm gonna
start loving the guy
just in all of his goofy annoying
heartbreaking glory
and i'm gonna go about controlling the
things i can control
i'm gonna let him know that he's loved
and that i'm heartbroken
i'm gonna be frustrated
but i'm not i'm gonna stop carrying that
stuff around because you're not gonna go
you do love the guy you don't like him
but you love the guy
he's the dad of your kids he's done a
good job
he's
incredibly lazy unfathomably lazy
i don't know how he got untangled from
this and by the way you can make a new
deal you can say all right deal's over
now i'm making a new one you're welcome
to do that
but here's i'm trying to get you i'm not
trying to if he was on the phone i can
promise she'll be letting him have it
what i'm
want you to
come to realization is that nagging
complaining
throwing stuff at people never ever
works it doesn't work
and what it does in the process is it
drags you down
and i want you to get back to somebody
that you respect that you love that you
treat with dignity
and it's not through grinding it out and
exercise that's part of it but it's also
man i'm gonna get back to joy what are
things that bring me joy
being here doesn't bring me joy so i'm
gonna go do that stuff hiring somebody
and having people over every friday that
brings me joy i'm gonna start doing that
what are the things that bring you joy
because that's all you can control your
thoughts and your actions and let me be
honest i know this is super super hard